اهلا بكم كشف وزير الاوقاف المصري محمد
مختار جمعه عن عزم وزارته اعاده النظر في
قواعد اقامه صلاه الجمعه في المساجد وعن
قصر الخطابه على الازهريين وهو ما دعى
البعض الى الربط بين هذا الامر وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين التي تعتبرها السلطات
جماعه ارهابيه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في محورين ما هي اسباب الربط بين
تنظيم العمل الدعوي وجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وهل يعتبر هذا التضييق محاوله من
السلطات للضغط من اجل ضمان الفصل بين
العمل الدعوي
والسياسي
لم تتوقف محاولات وزاره الاوقاف المصريه
على مدى الاسابيع الاخيره عن المضي قدما
فيما وصفته بتنظيم اقامه صلاه الجمعه في
المساجد وذلك بالزام الائمه بخطبه موحده
وبمنع غير الازهريين من الخطاب وقد وصل
الامر الى حد وقف ائمه عن العمل واحالتهم
على التحقيق لخروجهم عن الخطبه الموحده او
بدعوه انتمائهم الى جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كما حررت محاضر في مراكز الشرطه
بعدد من المحافظات ضد ائمه وخطباء قاموا
بالخطابه من دون ترخيص كما حررت محاضر ضد
رواد مساجد منعوا ائمه الوزاره من القاء
خطبه
الجمعه تخوض السلطات في مصر معركه من نوع
اخر يدعمها خطاب اقصائي يعجز اصحابه عن
ادراك الشعره الفاصله بين الاسلاميين
والاسلام وبين الاخوان المسلمين
والمسلمين هذا نقيب احدى اكبر نقابات
المهن الحره في مصر يفخر بعدم حفظه ايه من
القران الكريم كدليل بانه غير اخواني
واعتصموا بحبل الله جميعا ولا
تفرقوا واذكروا اذ كنتم
اعداء الله عل واذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم اذ كنتم اعداء فالف بين قلوبكم
فاصبحتم بنعمه ه اخوانا استغفر الله
العظيم بس عشان تعرفوا ان انا مش اخان
مسلمين لو كنت اخوان مسلمين كان زماني
و وبصرف النظر عما يصدره اداء كهذا من
فكره بان الاخوان المسلمين يحفظون القران
وهو ما يسجل لهم لا عليهم في مجتمع يعلي
من شان الدين فان ممارسات على مستوى اكبر
تفجر ما تزال جدلا حول مغزاها وجدواها مثل
المطارده التي تخوضها وزاره الداخليه ضد
ملصق يدعو للصلاه على النبي وهو منعكس
موجات من السخريه على مواقع التواصل وفي
الشوارع تتهكم مما وصف بسطحيه السلطات وهي
تحاول تلبس الانفتاح الليبرالي فتلاحقه
عباره مكتوبه لا تجريمها دول الصقور
العلمانيه لا يغيب ايضا عن هذا المشهد
قرار وزاره الاوقاف الاخير بوضع ما سمتها
قواعد لصلاه الجمعه وهي تسميه اثارت
لذاتها جدلا فقهيا وانتهت الى عدم اقامه
هذه الصلاه في
650 مسجدا وزاويه في الاسكندريه ثاني اكبر
مدن مصر لعدم وجود خطباء ازهريين تثق فيهم
الوزاره بينما يواصل من يشاء من ممثلين
وغيرهم الخوض في قضايا دينيه متجاوزين كل
الخطوط الحمر في ايات معينه بتدرس في
المدارس الابتدائي انا شايفها خطر خطا دي
ايات قرانيه مظبوط بس انت اخترت انت اخترت
ايات معينه عشان تعلمها للطفل ست سنين
فلازم تختار بعنايه رحل الاخوان المسلمون
عن حكم مصر واودع السجون وما يزال خصومهم
اصحاب العهد الجديد يحرثون في حقل الغام
يخلطون بين ما هو ديني وسياسي حيث الخيط
رفيع والخطا
قاتل موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين في
الاستديو الداعيه والباحث الاسلامي الشيخ
عصام تليمه ومن واشنطن الدكتور توفيق حميد
كبير باحثين في معهد بوتو معده الدراسات
السياسيه اهلا بكم شيخ تليمه ما هي اسباب
الربط بين تنظيم العمل الدعوي وجماعه
الاخوان برايك بين تنظيم العمل الدوي
وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين لا يوجد ربط الا
الرابط الامني فقط هذا فيما يعني واضح جدا
لان في النهايه اذا نظرنا الى المساجد او
الخطباء الذين يمنعون من خطباء وائمه
الاخوان المسلمين علميا وفائ وشهادات هم
من اكفا الناس بما شهد به الوزاره
ويعني في تعيينهم ومسوغات التعيين اجريت
عليهم المسابقات والشروط التي اجريت على
كل الخطباء والائمه هذا من حيث ائمه
الاخوان الذين هم في وزاره الاوقاف حتى
العلماء والدكاتره اللي محكوم عليهم
باحكام مثلا نموذج يعني الدكتور عبد الله
بركات ومحكوم عليه بالاعدام عميد كليه
الدعوه يعني كل اللي بيتخرجوا من كليه
الدعوه بيتعينوا في وزاره الاقف خطباء
كلهم تلامذته يعني انت النهارده اللي انت
بتعينهم النهارده مقر بيهم وتعتمد تقول ان
لا يرقى للمنابر الا الازهريين طب ما انت
طلعت الازهريين اللي هم خارجين مين تلامذه
مين عبد الرحمن البر عبد الله بركات اللي
انت مديهم اعدام متهم بانهم قطع طرق لقطع
طريق اليوب فطبعا كلها يعني اسباب لا قيمه
لها الا اسباب امنيه وحتى اكدها انا صاحب
تجربه شخصيه في سنه 97 جاني تعييني كبقيه
الالاف من زملائي منعت من التعيين وذهبت
لوكيل وزاره الاوقاف ان انا بمسوغ معين
اعين تخيلي رد وكيل وزاره الاوقاف عل ايه
ايه قلت له يعني قال لي لابد من اجازه
الامن وسبب المنع امنيا قلت له طب
والاجازه العاليه من الازهر قال لا قيمه
لها عندنا وزهري بجبه وعمه زي يعني
الاسباب واضحه جدا انها اسباب امنيه ليس
ال كيف يعني امنيه يعني كيف انه انت ممكن
تكون ارهابي مثلا لا مش ارهابي اذا انت لك
اي نشاط ديني ايجابي معارض للحاكم وليس
مؤيد للحاكم انت لا غير مرغوب فيك في ان
تخطب تمنع من الخطابه واذا كنت معين كما
عينت بقوه القانون عينت بقضيه يعني هذه
التهمه
اي يعني التعبير عنها يكون بانك مرفوض
امنيا عندما تكون معارض للنظام يقولون لك
انت مرفوض امنيا لا يقولون انت لانك معارض
سوف امنعك بقوللك امنيا هو بيجي له اوامر
الامن في الخفاء لكن واضح في الاول انك
بتقابل الامن قبلها ده قبل الثوره انك
الاول بيعمل لك مقابله مع الامن انت مطلوب
بمقابله عند الامن فبي سومك كما سومت انك
مطلوب تشتغل معان يعني كيكون مرشد في قلب
المسجد على المصلين والا والا بترفض طيب ا
دكتور توفيق حميد ما الذي تسعى اليه اذا
السلطات المصريه من خلال هذا التضييق ومن
خلال قصر الخطابه على الازهريين
اي والالزام بالائمه بخطبه
موحده
نعم شكرا على سؤالك اعتقد ان الدافع
الرئيسي للسلطات المصريه هو قضيه امن
البلاد ا فاحنا راينا كثير من المساجد
والزوايا اللي ما كانش فيها نوع من
السيطره ومعرفه ما يدري بداخلها الدعاء
بعضهم بيدعو الى الكراهيه والعنف واحيانا
الارهاب احيانا قد يتم من خلال ذلك ف ان
توضع يضع لها قانون بحيث تنظم هذه المساله
وانا لا ارى الامر هنا يعني خاص بالاخوان
لو تلاحظي حضرتك السلفيين بعضهم برض ممكن
يتاثر او خطيب عادي برض لا تابع لاخوان
ولا سلفيين ممكن يتاثر فانا الامر هنا مش
قضيه اخوان وفقط وليس قضيه نقد للحكم كما
ذكر الضيف
الفاضل الحكم في مصر على الجرائد المشهوره
كل يوم بيطبع في مقالات بتنزل ضد بعض
الاشياء السياسيه فانا اعتقد ان السبب
والدافع الرئيسي ومحاوله حمايه مصر من
الارهاب الناتج عن
الفكر الديني المتط وانا شخصيا عشت في
حياتي في سنه 79 و8 كليه طب جامعه القاهره
القصر العيني كنت عضو في الجماعه
الاسلاميه وكنت اذهب الى مساجد الاوقاف
والمساجد الاخرى اللي هي ما كانش عليها
سيطره وبكلمه بكلمه حق يعني مساجد الاوقاف
لم ادعى ذات يوم الى كراهيه اللي هي تبعه
للازهر او عنف او غيره ولكن على النقيد من
ذلك انا شهدت بنفسي وسمعت الكثير من الخطب
التي تدعوك صوره رهيبه الى كراهيه
الاخر
وبغضه وتنتهي بك الى التطرف فاعتقد ان هذا
الموضوع هذه نقطه مهمه سا ساسال سماحه
الشيخ عنها ولكن قبل ذلك انت قلت الامر لا
يقتصر او او المقصود به ليس الاخوان
المسلمين السلفيون سوف ايضا يتاثرون بذلك
وطبعا سيتاجرون هذا صحيح ولكن ثمم راى
تركيز في هذا الموضوع على الاخوان اليوم
السابع
مثلا الجريده المصريه في تاريخ السبت 14
يونيو 2014 عنوان الرئيس كان للخبر وزاره
الاوقاف تعلن سيطرتها على خطبه الجمعه
وتوقف
12000 خطيب اخواني اذا 12000 خطيب اخواني
ماذا افهم من
ذلك شوفي لو كان هو الخبر فقط الاخوان
المسلمين يبقى الخبر مش كافي لوصف الحقيقه
لان ما اعلمه ان السلفيين كانوا معت على
هذا القانون وابدوا شيء من الاعتراض بعضهم
فاعتقد ان الخبر هنا لا يصف حقيقه الواقع
وقد يكون حضرتك عارفه منشتات الصحف حتى
هنا في امريكا ساعات بياخد جزء من الحقيقه
ويكبرها لان هي دي اللي وات كان كاتش
اتنشن يعني تخلي الناس تبص على الجريده
فقد يكون العنوان استخدم كلمه الاخو لكن
لما تري القرار وحيس هو قرار فتفاصيل خبر
تقول فعلا 12000 خطيب اخوان يعني ما
تلاقيش في القرار ذاته اي اتجاه يقول لك
يقول لك انا ضد الاخوان بعينهم او غيره
لكن هي محاوله تنظيميه لمنع الخطبه
الداعيه للكراهيه والداعيه للبغضاء او
العنف فانا اراه قرار موزون جدا ومحتاجين
في الفتره دي في مصر لان في ناس واولاد
وشباب بيتطور كما احنا شايفين في العراق
بيتم ايه وفي س دور احداث مرع دكتور توفيق
فقط يعني للامانه يعني نقلا عن الخبر في
تفاصيل خبر لانك اي اقتصر انتقادك على
العنوان في الخبر نفسه بالحرف جاء فيه
استبعدت الوزاره 12000 خطيب اخواني من
مساجدها وابعدت 14000 خطيب غير ازهريين عن
الخطابه بمساجد انصار السنه والجمعيه
الشرعيه والدعاه ودعوه الحق اذا في تفاصيل
الخبر موجود العنوان نفسه سؤال لك سماحه
الشيخ اشار دكتور توفيق الى مساله مهمه
جدا هنالك خطب هو سمعها بنفسه تحث على
الكراهيه وتحرض على العنف اذا من حق
الدوله ان تنظم هذه الامور اذا كانت
الدوله ضد العنف اما اذا كانت الدوله هي
قائده العنف تنفيذا مش فكر بس الدوله التي
اصدت الانقلاب تحديدا عنف قتلت مصلين اذا
كانت المساله مساله مساجد واحرقت مساجد
وقتلت رجالا ونساء و في اعتداءات على
اعراض اذا كانت الدوله عنيفه من حق الشيخ
ان ان يحرض على هكملها والدوله تحالفت مع
شيوخ من ابرز دعاه العنف ياسر بهامي وحزب
النور في ادبيات ياسر بهامي وللاسف ماعرفش
انها هتسير السؤال ك تجت لكم كتابه كتابه
اسمه المنه وبيقول فيما لم يقرا المنه
فليس منه يح لكن اوقفته ما انا جايلك هقول
لك اوقفته ليه دلوقتي يقول في كتاب المنه
ان كل من ينادي بفصل الدين عن السياسه فهو
كافر كفر اكبر يعني يحكم على 90% من اللي
نزلوا في 30 يوني اللي تحالف معاهم واللي
في 3 يوليو بالكفر و ما يعرفوش ان ده نص
ولاخ لماذا منع اقوللك لماذا منع ياسر
برامي لم يمنع الا بعد انتخابات الرئاسه
لان شعبيه حزب كانوا بيرنوا عليها تنزل
الناس في الشارع في الاستفتاء عقاب واضح
واضح لم يمنع لو تلاحظ القانون نازل من
زمان ونازل فتره طويله ولم يطبق على دعاه
السلفيين الا بعد الاستفتاء العدد بدا
الشعبيه تنزل في في انتخابات الرئاسه وضح
ان شعبيتهم وال الشباب لهم في الارضيه
ارضيتم الشعبيه وقواعدهم اصبحت في صدام
واضح ضدهم لانهم اللي هم كانوا بيخفوا فيه
مرسي اصبحوا يعيدوا فيه السيسي بوضوح جدا
فالمسالة رجل امن ببساطه الراجل ما بيحضر
ما عندوش ماده بلي النهارده الدعاء نجوم
الفضائيات مين دعاه السلفيين والدعاء
العاديين اللي ليسوا ازهريين عمرو خالد
ومصطفى حسني وعز مسعود ومحمد حسن ومحمد
حسين يعقوب ولا واحد ازهري فين علماء
الازهر يعني طيب دكتور دكتور توفيق فين
علماء الازهر
اذا والله علماء الازهر
ا عن يعني واجبهم حاليا اعتقادي طرح
مفاهيم تكون مسالمه تدعو الى تفهم الاخر
او قبول الاخر ترفض العنف بوضوح ا واعتقد
هم في مرحله تغيير حاليا يعني انا ما اسمع
ما يصل الي من معلومات ان في مرحله تغيير
وتجديد وتطوير للفكر في المرحله الحاليه
انا ما اقدرش اقول ان ان ان يعني ان
السابق كان شيء مثالي ولكن انا اتمنى ان
الازهر يقوم بدور اكثر ايجابيه في نشر
الفكر السليم الذي يمنع الناس من من
كراهيه الاخر ولا يدعوهم الى التطرف بصوره
او باخرى وي تعليق سريع جدا فقط ثواني على
نقطه الاخوان والسلفيين فالعنوان قال
12000 اخوان ولكن هذا لا يعني انه لا يوجد
سلفيين فقد يوجد 200 الف سلفي ايضا ولكن
لم يذكروا في العنوان او في المقاله فوجود
الاخوان بالنص هنا لا يعني انه لا يوجد
غيرهم ده اللي انا عاوز اقوله فقد يوجد
غيرهم ولكنهم لم يذكروا لم يذكروا في هذه
المقاله و ولكن السيد سماحه الشيخ رد على
هذا الموضوع قال السلفيون
او الغير الاخوانيين كانوا يعقبون بمي
اتمنع يا فندم ا اه لا لكن فسر فسره على
انه عقاب لانه بعد الانتخابات عقاب لهم
بعد الانتخابات وقد يفسر ايضا على انهم
كلات فصل على الاخوان
يعني لا ده تحليل افتراضي لكن من عنده لكن
الواقع هو ان هو طالما في ولو مثل واحد
لحد غير اخواني يبقى اذا الموضوع مش مقصود
به فقط الاخوان ولكن مقصود به حمايه
الدوله من الفكر المتطرف الذي استشرى في
الكثير من الزوايا والجوامع وبدون اي
كنترول او سيطره وادى الى مشاكل يا ريته
فكر وقف على العقل فقط ولكن انه امتد الى
اعمال وافعال تخريبيه طيب ساعد اليكما
ضيفي الكرام بعد فاصل قصير نتناول بعده
اعتبار بعض المشايخ والائمه تضييق السلطات
محاوله لضمان الفصل بين نشاط الدعوي
والعمل السياسي نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من
جديد شيخ تليمه انت فسرت مساله مثلا منع
ياسر برهامي او عبد المنعم شحاب بانهم
عوقبوا بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه لم يكن
جمهورهم حاضرا في التصويت ولكن ثمه من
يقول بان السلطات تريد الضغط من اجل الفصل
اي صله بين النشاط الدعوي والعمل السياسي
للجماعات السلفيه والجماعات السلفيه هذا
لا اعتقد ابدا الجماعات السلفيه يعني هي
سند وظهير لانقلاب 3 يوليو بدليل حضورهم
في ا وقت الانقلاب مع بابا الكنيسه مع شيخ
الازهر مع رئيس الاعلى القضاه كان الهدف
ان يكون موجود حد يمثل الطيار الاسلامي
على ان الطار الاسلامي ليس على قلب رجل
واحد وان في فصيل بيمثلها فصيل معتدل
وكويس وزي الفل حتى رم تجديدات افكارهم
الاخيره ان هنرشح امراه ولا مانع على
القائم ان يترشح قبطي لكن في النهايه
اكتشف هؤلاء الناس ان هذا التوجه ليس له
ارضيه حقيقيه على الارض مش موجوده بان فين
النهارده انصار حزب النور حتى المنشد اللي
عاملهم انشوده طلع بعدها انشوده ضدهم اللي
كانت ان شدتهم الرئيسيه ابو عمار واعتقل
بتحريض منهم يعني المساله ليست مساله يعني
مش مساله ان لا الناس دي افكارها بدليل
عبد المنعم الشحات نفسه اللي قال قبل
الانقلاب وقبله بفتره الديمقراطيه حرام
وكفر وحتى لما سقطو في انتخابات 2012
الشعب ققول مش انت بتقول الديمقراطيه حرام
مش عايزينك تمشي في الحرام وسطوه فهذا
اللي قال الديمقراطيه حرام هو تحليف ل 3ه
يوليو ما كانوش عارفين ضراي عبد المن من
الشحات ان بيقول الديمقراطيه كفر وحرام
عارفين مش عارفين ان السلفيين اللي بيحرم
التصوير و بيحرم
المراه وكذا ومواقفه معروفه ضد المراه
وعلامه الشفروليه وعلامه الشفروليه ان
علامه الشفروليه صليب يجب ان تزال فتوى
لياسر ب من فتاوى يا كاس العال كره كاس
العالم برض كرا فتوى فيه الا يعلم لهذا
الق من خطاب هذا الفصيل مش عارف خطابه
كويس عارفه بس هو يعلم ان هذا الفصيل ربي
في احضانه مساله معروفه ولا عشان ما
تقوليش احنا مش موجودين عشان يدافعوا مش
هتكلم في القصه دي لكن معلوم للجميع ان
هذا التوجه توجه تربيته امنيه بدليل كل
اللي اخذوه على مرسي الان بيقف على الام
السيسي ولا ينطقون لما قالوا الشيعه لا
الملف الشيعي وهاجوا على مرسي لما مرسي
فتح باب السياحه للايرانيين طب رئيس ايران
دعي لحضور تنصيب حفل تنصيب السيسي ما
نطقوها وجود الان قوافل شيعيه الى مصر
زياره انا مش ضد ده كله ب بس بقول لك
المواقف لما التناقض لما تقال اخوانه
الدوله وادعوا ان كان في 13000 وظيفه وطلع
كذب طب النهارده علمنه الدوله اللي انت
المفروض انك اسلامي لماذا لا تتكلم عنها
الى تفاصيل كثيره جدا الخروج على محمد
مرسي جائز السيسي رئيس شرعي ولا يجوز
الخروج عليه وهو لسه متولي بقى له يومين
هذا التناقض في الخطاب لا هو هؤلاء الناس
عايزين يقدموا السبت حتى يحموا يوم الاحد
في السلطه الجديده ولكن هم لا يوجد عندهم
ما يقدموا خلاص يعني انتهوا رصيدهم انتهى
تماما عند الشعب وعند حتى سلطه الانقلاب
دكتور توفيق هل لديك تفسير لهذا التناقض
الذي اشار اليه الشيخ تليمه واعطانا امثله
وايضا حتى السيسي نفسه بعد انتخابه استخدم
يعني تعابير دينيه في خطابه القصير
والطويل مرات عده هل يقتصر استخدام الدين
على من يمسك بالحكم ومن يعارض الحكم لا
غير مسموح له ان يتحدث
بالدين
ا شوفي حضرتك المشكله ليست في التحدث
بالدين ولكن في كيفيه التحدث بالدين فاذا
تحدثت بالدين لنشر مبادئ السلام والوفاق
بين البشر وتعارف الحضارات فاهلا وسهلا
بذلك ولا يوجد عندي مشكله ان يقولها احد
من الاخوان او السلفيين او رئيس الجمهوريه
القضيه هنا قضيه طريقه استخدام الدين ولكن
اذا استخدم الدين بطريقه تدعو الكراهيه
والبغضاء والعنف وتجريم الاخرين العدوان
عليهم فانا اقف ضد من يستخدمه بهذه
الطريقه سواء كان من الاخوان او من
السلفين او من القوه السياسيه يعني
الموضوع هو هنا ايه قضيه واضحه ومن حيث
مبدا استخدام الدين فالرئيس الامريكي مثلا
حينما يقسم على البيبل هنا يعني مش حاجه
مستغربه وجود شيء من الدين ولكن ما يهم في
الاور ه مفهوم الدين وانا ما ارى من
الرئيس السيسي حتى الان ان مفهومه عن
الدين وما عرضه شيء مشرف واعتقد يحسن صوره
الاسلام في العالم اجمع حينما قال ان
الدين لابد ان يخرج من مجرد
الطقوس للافعال والتعامل بين البشر فاعتقد
الرجل اشار الى محور القضيه الاهتمام
بالدين الطقسي دون الاهتمام بالمعاملات
بين البشر فمفهوم عن الدين مفهوم رائع وما
رايته الى الان شيء يشرف وانا يعني سانقل
الى ال حتى يعرف الناس حتى في امريكا هو
ليس يعني دكتور هو غير ازهري اصلا وهو
يعني ايضا في في في المقابل انت عن عندما
تضيق على هؤلاء لا تستطيع ان تحجر على فكر
انت تستطيع ان تحبس الجسد لكنك لا تستطيع
ان تحبس الافكار هل هذا هو الاسلوب الامثل
لوقف اذا كان هنالك تحريض وعنف هل هذا
الطريقه الامثل لانك سوف تواجه اجتماعات
سريه سوف تواجه مزيدا من الكبت والتعبير
عن هذا الكبت بمزيد من
التحريض انا ارى نقطتك وانا ارى ان
الاسلوب الامثل يكون بمعاقبه من يستخدم
الدين لنشر العنف وليس مجرد محاوله ايقافه
لان محاوله ايقافه ممكن يستخدم الفيسبوك
التويتر اليوتيوب واصبح من الصعب النهارده
تسيطري على كل شيء فاعتقد قد يكون يعني
الاسلوب الامثل هو ان يكون في عقوبه واضحه
لمن يستخدم
الدين لتحفيز الناس على على العنف ا ولكن
للاسف في الظروف الحاليه في مصر بياتي رجل
خطيب مثلا في مسجد ويدعو الى العنف
والكراهيه لو جاءت القوات الامن واخذته
بيحدث نوع من المشاكل الرهيبه وينتهي بعنف
اكثر فاحنا عندنا مشكله خاصه قد تستدعي
انك تضطري تستخدمي اشياء قد لا تكون
مثاليه مثل المنع ولكنها قد تكون ضروريه
لمنع اهتزاز الدوله في المرحله الحاليه
حتى تستطيع ان تقف على اقدامها مره اخرى ا
شيخ تليمه لديك تعليق على هذا الموضوع
بانه قد لا يكون هذا هو الحل مث هذا الحل
قد لا يكون مثاليا لكن مضطر الدوله لكي
تنظم
امور يعني الحديث بالدين وبتحريض والك
ممكن ان يشت انا بس ز اوجه للدكتور توفيق
معلش اسمحي لي بقول ان خطاب السيسي عرض
رائع للدين لانه ضد العنف هو انا موقف
الدوله تتاخذ كم موقفها من العنف كان ولا
فعل ده رئيس مطلوب ابص لفعله فعل السيسي
ايه من لاثه سبعه لحد النهارده كموقف من
العنف كل اللي ماتوا دول وموقفه راجل زي
الفل كلامه يسامح ويعرض اسلام زي الفل ده
عامل من عوامل رده الناس عن الاسلام اذا
كان ده الاسلامي اللي هتقدمه ده واحد
اثنين في دعاه ومشايخ قالوا عنف وحرضوا عن
ال عنف في وجوده علي جمعه لما قال اضرب في
المليان وقال على اللي فراب على سنتنا و
بمشايخ ده مش خطاب عنف امال ده خطاب ايه
ده خطاب الحب السلام والوئام اللي المفروض
نصدره وقال في وسط كام 500 قياده منهم
وزير الداخليه وزير الدفاع عبد الفتاح
السيسي فهل في هل توجه اي كلمه لوم او
مراجعه لعلي جمعه ولكل المشايخ اللي
جابوهم يحرضوا الناس على فض ربع ونهض بهذا
العنف غير المسبوق في تاريخ مصر بالكامل
ما حصلش حتى في الايام الاحتلال حتى
الفرنسيين لما دخلوا الازهر بالخيل ما
عملوش الكلام ده في الازهر ولا في الجامع
ولا في الناس طيب هذا مفروغ منه اوضحت هذه
النقطه انا لدي سؤال تعقيبا على حتى ولو
كان هو يفعل ذلك وهنالك مشايخ بحضوره
حرضوا على العنف انت ك طرف اخر مقابل كيف
يمكنك ان تسيطر على من يحرض على العنف في
في المساجد بدون ان تمنع وبدون ان تترك
الامور هكذا على ما ما يعني على فوضى حتى
اتهم انسانا بانه حرض على العنف ينبغي
عندي من دليل ده موظف عندي في وزاره
الاوقاف المفروض انا في الاول ما الماده
العلميه اللي التي قدمتها لهذا الخطيب ده
وزاره انا تابع لها الدورات العلميه اللي
اخذوها العلماء والفقهاء والخطباء ايه
الدورات اللي دت لهم ايه ثم بعد ذلك عندي
رقباء مفتشين يعني النهارده الخطباء اللي
اتفصل بقلهم ككم سنه في الاوقاف 15 و سنه
يعني 20 سنه كان بيحرض على العنف ايام
مبارك اللي كان فيها قبضه الدوله قويه
يعني لم يكتشف انه راجل بيحرض الا
النهارده كلام مش منطقي لماذا لا ينتقى
الى الخطباء المعروفين المحبوبين من الناس
المشهورين اللي عندهم علم في مقابل خطباء
تانيين معروفين بسوء العلم ولا اقول سوء
السلوك لان ده كلام ماقدرش اهم لكن ولا
غير موجودين بالاسم معروفين يعني شكرا
جزيلا لك الداعيه والبحث الاسلامي عصام
تليمه واشكر من واشنطن دكتور توفيق حميد
كبير الباحثين في مععد بوتوماك للدراسات
السياسيه واشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد
القاء
ا